[Musique]
ça
bonsoir tout le monde alors ce soir je
vais vous parler d'être noir et de la
vie dans l'univers
alors les tournants sont certainement
parmi les aspects les plus fascinants de
notre univers de plus on commence à
comprendre qu'ils jouent un rôle
fondamental dans l'évolution et le
développement des épaules mais
commençons par le commencement
que sont donc les tournois l'être humain
sont souvent perçus comme difficile
complexe à comprendre par la communauté
le public
néanmoins il s'avère qu'ils ne sont
caractérisés que par trois paramètres la
masse le moment angulaire c'est à dire
la vitesse à laquelle ils tournent sur
eux-mêmes et la charge électrique
uniquement ces trois paramètres
ces trois paramètres sont les éléments
fondamentaux à la compréhension des
trous noirs
qu'est ce que cela veut dire cela veut
dire que lorsque des astrophysiciens et
c'est de calculer la température la
dynamique la taille apparente du trou
noir
ils doivent nécessairement utiliser ces
trois paramètres la masse moment
angulaire et la charge électrique
j'ai envie de vous parler de taille
apparente il s'avère que dans la
définition la plus simple du trou noir
un trou noir est une masse fini avec une
taille nul
néanmoins lorsqu'on parle de trou noir
on parle beaucoup de foi du rayon de
schwarzschild le rayon de schwarzschild
c'est quelque chose qui définit une aire
de l'espace temps que l'on appelle
l'horizon des événements l'horizon des
événements c'est une surface imaginaire
qui n'est pas palpable mais qui est très
simple à comprendre
imaginez vous à la plage vous regarder
le coucher du soleil et vous avez
l'horizon qu'est-ce que l'horizon
l'horizon c'est une limite imaginaire
qui permet de définir l'ensemble des
événements que vous arrivez à avoir de
ce que vous n'arrivez pas à voir
il s'avère que l'horizon des événements
c'est exactement la même chose
c'est une limite imaginaire qui définit
l'ensemble des événements que vous
arrivez à avoir de ce qu'on n'arrivait
pas à voir mais moins ya une différence
notable entre l'horizon des événements
et l'horizon au coucher du soleil comme
vous pouvez l'imaginer
imaginez vous dans un avion vous
regarder au travers de votre boulot et
vous regarder l'horizon
l'horizon se meut cela veut dire qu'il
ya des événements qui y entrent dans
votre champ de vision
néanmoins si vous êtes très courageux
vous approchez d'un trou noir et vous
êtes extrêmement curieux et vous
dépasser l'horizon des événements que se
passe-t-il
eh bien vous ne pourrez plus revenir en
arrière même la lumière ne peut plus
revenir en arrière lorsqu'elle va au
delà de l'horizon des événements d'un
trou noir
pourquoi il faut savoir deux choses tout
d'abord il ya une limite de vitesse dans
l'univers la vitesse de la lumière
c'est un style qui nous l'a dit
basiquement pour pouvoir dépasser la
vitesse de la lumière il faut avoir une
énergie infinie
donc comment on peut pas accéder à une
il est impossible de dépasser la vitesse
de la lumière ça c'est la première chose
à comprendre
deuxième chose à comprendre il ya un
concept de vitesse de libération d'un
astre qu'est ce que la vitesse de
libération d'un astre c'est la vitesse
minimum qu'il faut atteindre pour
pouvoir se libérer de l'attraction
gravitationnelle d'un astre si vous
calculez pour la terre la vitesse de
libération d'un astre vous obtenez de la
terre pardon vous obtenez quelque chose
comme 40 mille kilomètres par heure cela
veut dire qu'il faut pouvoir accélérer
l'objet à cette vitesse pour qu'il sorte
d' influence gravitationnelle de la
terre maintenant si vous prenez la
vitesse de libération d'un trou noir
que se passe-t-il si vous la calculer à
l'horizon des événements cette surface
imaginaire et bien vous obtenez la
vitesse de la lumière
cela veut dire que si vous allez au delà
de l'horizon des événements et bien
nécessairement pour pouvoir sortir du
trou noir
il faut avoir une vitesse de libération
supérieure à celle de la lumière
et c'est pour ça qu'on ne peut pas
sortir d'un trou noir lorsqu'on va au
delà le d'horizon des événements même
pas la lumière et donc le trou noir et
noir alors mais imaginez que vous êtes
assez courageux et vous vous approchez
d'horizon des événements
vous allez hautevalle de raison des
événements que se passe-t-il et bien
vous allez être entraînés au centre du
trou noir et autres centres du trou noir
qu'est ce qu'il y a il ya ce qu'on
appelle une singularité
une singularité c'est un point de
l'espace temps avec une pression et une
densité infinie la singularité c'est un
vrai casse tête pour les physiciens cas
il faut avoir une vision complète de la
physique
il faut comprendre le macroscopique et
le mans
scopique qu'est ce que je veux dire
basiquement il ya deux théories
fondamentales en physique la relativité
générale qui nous permet de comprendre
le mouvement des galaxies l'univers et
les étoiles et il ya la théorie
quantique qui permet de comprendre les
atomes et bien la singularité
elle contient une physique avec ces deux
ingrédients
donc il faut avoir une théorie unifiée
pour pouvoir comprendre la singularité
si on nous on essaie d'obtenir une
théorie unifiée et ont fait des calculs
dessus qu'est ce qu'on obtient des
infinis et donc la singularité n'est
toujours pas comprise actuellement par
la communauté scientifique mais c'est
aussi un des sujets les plus
intéressants qu'ils existent donc
j'imagine que pour l'instant vous vous
dites les trous noirs ne sont pas
nécessairement les bienfaiteurs de
l'univers il s'avère qu'ils jouent un
rôle fondamental dans la création des
étoiles et des galaxies
mais commençons par le commencement le
big bang le big bang l'instant zéro
on ne sait pas comment le big bang a été
créé néanmoins juste après le big bang
il ya une phase d'expansion accélérée de
l'univers que l'on appelle l'inflation
juste après l'inflation il ya eu
création de la matière une seconde après
le big bang
cette création de la matière elle s'est
créée à partir d'un plasma de quarks
gluons des particules fondamentales et
cette matière ce sont les protons et les
neutrons les protons et neutrons forme
la plus part de la masse de notre corps
ce qui est intéressant avec les protons
et neutrons néanmoins c'est qu'ils ne
forment qu'une petite fraction de la
masse de l'univers et la communauté
scientifique a trouvé que de fait la
plupart de la masse de l'univers et bien
qu'on ne sait pas ce que c'est on
appelle ça la matière noire
la matière noire n'aimait pas de lumière
fait 84 % de la masse de l'univers et on
sait qu'elles existent uniquement par
l'influent ce qu'elle induit dans les
étoiles et les galaxies et si la matière
noire n'était autre que les trous noirs
au fond ça a du sens la matière ne me
mets pas de lumière les trous noirs ne
met pas non plus de lumière mais au
moins on sait que les trous noirs
existent
si les trous noirs font 100 % de la
matière eh bien ils ont été créées de
matière noire dont ils ont été créés au
début de l'univers en très très grande
quantité
c'est ce qu'on appelle les trous noirs
primordiaux avec cette théorie des
tournois primordiaux on arrive à obtenir
une masse pour cette remarque pour
qu'ils fassent 100 % de la matière noire
si on prend une masse de 10 à la
puissance 20 g c'est une masse typique
pour ce tournoi primordiaux eh bien il
pourrait faire 100 % de la matière noire
10 à l'absence 20 grammes c'est un petit
satellite de saturne prométhée et pour
cette masse on devrait avoir une taille
apparente donc un rayon de churchill ou
horizon des événements de 10 à la moins
8 cm dit cela - 8 cm c'est la taille
d'un atome
donc imaginez vous la taille d'un atome
contenant la masse d'une petite lune ce
qui est aussi fascinant avec ces trous
noirs primordiaux c'est que ceux qui
sont créés tout début de l'univers bien
ils ont une masse plus légère que ceux
qui sont créés après donc si on a une
petite fraction de cette rumeur
primordiaux qui sont créés une minute
après le big bang
eh bien il aurait une masse de 10 à la
puissance cinq masses solaires cent
mille fois la masse du soleil
si ces trous noirs sont créés et
commence à acre et et de la manière la
matière autour d'eux et produisent les
progéniteurs des galaxies dans l'univers
donc les trous noirs primordiaux aurait
pu être à l'origine des galaxies dans
l'univers si ces trous noirs primordiaux
sont à l'origine dé les galaxies dans
l'univers ils sont aussi indirectement à
l'origine des étoiles avoir des étoiles
vous me direz c'est bien car ça produit
une température agréable
par exemple sur terre où on pourrait
avoir production de la vie néanmoins
c'est une condition nécessaire mais pas
suffisante il faut avoir les éléments
chimiques nécessaires à la vie l'oxygène
et l'hydrogène le carbone il s'avère que
ces éléments là ils sont produits au
centre des étoiles et ils sont dispersés
dans la galaxie dans ce qu'on appelle la
supernova la supernova c'est un
événement cataclysmique une explosion
cataclysmique
qui dispersent les éléments nécessaires
à la vie mais essayons de comprendre
qu'est-ce qu'une étoile comment une
étoiles se forment les étoiles elle se
forme à partir d'un fragment de gaz et
de poussière ce fragment de gaz et de
poussières conapp sous les fils aux pros
de la propre gravité et sans typiquement
des étoiles d'une dizaine de masses
solaires
c'est ces étoiles continuent à collecter
jusqu'à un équilibre hydrostatique soit
atteint qu'est ce que ça veut dire
équilibre statique
cela veut dire qu'il ya une pression
interne qui contrebalance le collapse
gravitationnelle c'est à dire que
l'étoile ne bouge plus qu'elle est en
équilibre
à ce moment là la température augmente
au coeur de l'étoile et elle commence un
processus de fusion de l'hydrogène
elle commence à brûler de l'hydrogène
jusqu'à ce cas là on est plus lorsqu'on
a plus d'hydrogène au centre elle
commence à brûler de l'hélium
au moment où elle commence à brûler
d'hélium la température augmente ce qui
fait augmenter la luminosité et la
taille de l'école elle devient ce qu'on
appelle une géante rouge donc là elle
brûle de l'hélium elle continue à brûler
de l'hélium
jusqu'à ce qu'ils aient plus des lieux
au moment il ya plus les lieux elle
commence à brûler du carbone de
l'oxygène éventuellement dû faire au
moment où elle brûle du fer eh bien elle
doit donner plus d'énergie pour brûler
des faire que ce qu'elle en reçoit en
retour et l' équilibre hydrostatique et
brisé à ce moment là il ya ce qu'on
appelle la supernova les couches
externes de l'étoile sont expulsés dans
la galaxie est ce qu'il faut savoir
c'est que ces couches externes
contiennent tous les éléments essentiels
à la vie hydrogène carbone oxygène au
centre de l'étoile vous pouvez le voir
ici une image d'une supernova au centre
de l'étoile il ya un point blanc qui est
en fait le coeur de l'étoile qui n'a
plus cet équilibre hydrostatique
il n'y a plus de pression interdite qui
contrebalance la cre la gravitation et
donc les toiles collapse et un trou
art stellaire et n'est donc la naissance
des trous noirs stellaires est
exactement le même moment où les
éléments essentiels à la vie sont les
disperser dans l'univers je voudrais
terminer par une citation de steven
pinker un psychologue cognitiviste qui
dit il ya un siècle personne ne peut
prouver l'existence des trous noirs d'un
univers en expansion
deux séances sur les lunes de jupiter ou
de l'adn quoi de plus enrichissant que
de savoir que nous partageons une
origine commune avec tous les êtres
vivants que nous sommes proches des
chimpanzés des séquoias et des
mollusques et n'est ce pas une source
d'émerveillement de réaliser que le
faire dans notre sens et le calcium dans
nos eaux ont été créés dans le ventre
des supernovas merci
[Applaudissements]